well if you watched a lot of the
coverage of this story today on
television you likely came away with the
understanding that Julian Assange is
some kind of Russian spy who's in
trouble tonight because he stole
classified documents from the US
government that is not true it's
factually incorrect saying so is not a
defensive Asajj right here to promote
him or excuse any number of things he
said over the years that we disagree
with quite a lot but just so it's clear
whatever his sins
Assange did not steal documents from the
United States government he did not hack
the DNC servers he didn't break into
John Podesta's gmail account there is no
proof that he is working for the Russian
government wherever has worked for the
Russian government Assange has never
been charged with any of that and wasn't
today no matter what they tell you if
you're upset about the theft of
classified documents from the US
government and there is reason to be we
already know who did that a 22 year old
Army private named Bradley Manning now
called Chelsea Manning in 2013 Manning
pleaded guilty to stealing secret
material and got 35 years in prison for
it shortly after that Barack Obama
commuted Manning sentence this allowed
Manning to leave jail decades early go
back on television as a commentator and
then run for political office so if your
real concern is America's national
security you have someone to be angry at
Barack Obama and yet strangely nobody is
instead they're furious of Julian
Assange for printing the documents that
other people stole quote Julian Assange
has long been a wicked tool of Vladimir
Putin and the Russian intelligence
services wrote professional moralizer
Ben Sasse who also serves in the US
Senate he deserves to spend the rest of
his life in prison wicked the rest of
his life in prison
Edie I mean eight people and never faced
this kind of scorn not even close
nor for the record was a me never
extradited he died at 78 years old in
his own bed leaving behind 43 loving
children so what's going on here a
couple of things first Julian Assange
embarrassed virtually everyone in power
in Washington he published documents
that undermined the official story on
the Iraq war and Afghanistan he got
debbie Wasserman Schultz fired from the
DNC
he humiliated Hillary Clinton by showing
that the Democratic primaries were in
fact rigged pretty much everyone in
Washington has reason to hate Julian
Assange rather than just admit that
straightforwardly he made us look like
buffoons so now we're sending him to
prison instead they're denouncing him as
you guessed it a Russian agent watch
Senator Richard Blumenthal explain
justice should come to Julian Assange
for his role in Russian meddling in our
election and the sooner the better
okay so once again just to be totally
clear no one has ever shown that Julian
Assange is a Russian agent the
indictment against him today does not
say that it doesn't mention Russia at
all but that has not stopped virtually
every politician in Washington from
repeating senator Blumenthal's line
including many Republicans Robert Muller
nearly killed the rush of collusion hoax
Julian Assange is allowing them to keep
it alive
you'd think journalists would say
something about this Assange is after
all one of them what do you call a man
who publishes news for a living Assange
is no sleazier than many journalists in
Washington he's definitely not more
anti-american he's broken stories the
New York Times would have won Pulitzer
for and yet many of his colleagues have
disowned him oh please wrote Alexia
Campbell of Vox the same sanchez no
journalist we know who he works for
meaning Russia Julian Assange is not a
journalist explain Jelani Cobb of The
New Yorker without actually explaining
Kendall an Ian of NBC who doesn't so
much cover the national security state
as write memos on its behalf
noted that quote many believe that as if
Asajj ever was a journalist those days
ended a long time ago at NBC when they
tell you many believe something it means
they believe it so while the hostility
to Julian Assange well well that former
Democratic staffer and current CNN
anchor Jim Shiro explained Assange is
real sin was preventing Hillary Clinton
from becoming president he is central to
several cases he's central to Russian
interference in the election the US
intelligence views him as a middle
mana cut out that he was in effect part
of this interference he's central to to
the questions about what the Trump
administration or Trump campaign I
should say knew prior to the release of
those materials right what were the
communications between Roger stone etc
it's possible that this is something
President Trump himself is not
particularly excited about it's
remarkable to watch us it's bewildering
actually there was a time not so long
ago really when reporters didn't applaud
the arrest of other journalists for
publishing information in 1971 the
Washington Post in The New York Times
published a trove of stolen classified
documents about the Vietnam War it was
called the Pentagon Papers remember that
liberals loved it
books were written celebrating their
bravery as recently as 2011 The
Washington Post saw the connection quote
a conviction of Julian Assange would
also cause collateral damage to American
media freedoms a Post op-ed said that
year quote it is difficult to
distinguish Assange or WikiLeaks from
the Washington Post and that's true but
that was before the Trump election and
the total war that followed a war in
which the media have definitively chosen
aside press freedom sure as long as we
agree with your politics the First
Amendment well that all depends who'd
you vote for the guardians of speech are
now the enemies of speech the people
charged with policing power are now
colluding with power there's a reason
you see John Brennan on NBC all the time
they're all in the same team now we're
not saying any of this to defend Julian
Assange we just want to be absolutely
clear about who hurts this country more
and it's not him